in the decade between 1976 and 86 one of
California's most prolific criminals
tormented the state with 50 rapes and a
dozen murders an upcoming book by the
late wife of comedian Patton Oswald
investigates the little-known Golden
State Killer in a preview of tomorrow's
48 hours Tracy Smith explores how her
work could help capture the elusive
killer comedian and actor Patton Oswalt
has made a career out of getting laughs
my wife is 10 times smarter than me she
but there was rarely anything funny and
his wife Michelle McNamara's line of
work she blogged and wrote about true
crime stories especially unsolved
murders she had a mind for the details
of true crime the way that other people
have for a baseball or me for films were
just in her head Michelle had learned
about a criminal known as the East Area
rapist original Nightstalker
between 1976 and 1986
he'd been responsible for 50 rapes and
12 murders across California before he
suddenly vanished to this day no one
knows who he is she started looking at
the devastation at this guy rot you're
taunting the police are taunting the
population and you you're never caught
Michelle McNamara had found her next
subject what's fascinating to me about
this case is it is rich with so many
clues and frankly it should be soft she
would write about the case in LA
magazine rebranding the suspect with a
more memorable name the Golden State
Killer a book deal soon followed the
great tragedy of this case to me is it's
not better Michelle met with
investigators like Erica hutch craft
from the Orange County sex crimes unit
she had such good insight and I think
it's because other investigators had
trusted her they told her things that
weren't in some of the original files
Contra Costa County investigator Paul
holes says he came to view Michelle
McNamara as part of the team once she
earned my trust
she literally became my investigative
partner like other investigators
Michelle was motivated by the pain and
terror of victims like Jane Carson
Sandler
Jane was raped in her home by the
assailant in 1976 it was sheer terror
what is he gonna murder us he's gonna
kill us what's he gonna do to us
the suspect relished tormenting his
victims often calling them after the
attack investigators recorded one of his
phone calls
[Applause]
so who does this voice belong to who is
the man behind the mask
Michelle McNamara thought she was
getting close to finding him
then she died unexpectedly in her sleep
last year in my gut I think he is gonna
be caught because of what Michelle did
and because of what all the cops did
before her and Tracy Smith is with us
now good morning Tracy
how did patton oswalt essentially make
sure that Michelle's work continued even
though she died before finishing this
book well he didn't feel he could do it
justice on his own so he enlisted the
help of a researcher that she was
working with and a true crime writer and
they're going to finish this thing it's
very important to him that he finishes
her work with their help how did she die
and how is he doing it was a combination
of prescription drugs and an undiagnosed
heart condition and it was shocking
devastating he's now a single parent
he's sad but he speaks so eloquently
about his grief that I really feel like
anybody who's lost someone or who's
loved was someone you can get something
out of this hour is her work making a
difference do you think on the case oh
yeah it's gotten investigators to work
together and maybe don't we'll find out
who this person is Thank You Tracy Tracy
thanks you can see Tracy's full report
48 hours the Golden State killer
tomorrow night at 10:00 9:00 central
right here on CBS